mi esposa y yo recientemente recibimos
un paquete de jabones aromáticos y ambos
tenemos muchas ganas de vivir la
experiencia de bañarnos con cada uno de
los jabones pero no estamos dispuestos a
compartir los jabones con el otro y es
por eso que tenemos un pequeño dilema
cómo podemos compartir estas tres barras
de jabón de tal manera que
experimentemos todos los olores y es que
aquí puedes ver que tenemos una barra de
jabón y olor a rosa
aquí otro jabón olor a vainilla se me
ocurren y otro otro olor a sándalo que
por cierto es un olor delicioso y bueno
mi esposa dice que tiene una idea
excelente lo que dice es que tenemos
tres barras de jabón es con esto
empezamos empezamos con tres barras de
jabón es ya estas tres barras de jabón
es las voy a dividir en dos grupos
iguales y cómo vas a hacer eso bueno
pues ella me dice que va a tomar un
cuchillo o tal vez unas tijeras muy
grandes para poder partir estos jabones
a la mitad
estos jabones a la mitad a partidos por
aquí a partir de este otro también a la
mitad y este otro también lo va a partir
a la mitad tal manera que queden varios
pedazos de jabón y de hecho una buena
pregunta es ideal saber cuántos pedazos
de jabón vamos a obtener en total
cuántos pedazos de jabón vamos a obtener
en total y si no has visto mis vídeos
sobre división de fracciones creo que
ahí puedes encontrar la respuesta pero
entonces lo que va a ser mi esposa fue
tomar estas tres barras de jabones y
dividirlas y dividirlas entre dos grupos
iguales y bueno yo quiero que pienses un
poco en esto porque si nosotros pensamos
solamente en la parte que a mí me toca
déjame pegarla para acá para que a veces
de manera visual esta va a ser la parte
que me toca solamente a mí ok pues ésta
la parte de salman khan o lo que me está
compartiendo mi esposa de estos jabones
aromáticos entonces la parte
de salman la parte de salman date cuenta
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tener tres mitades es decir que esto es
un medio de jabón aquí tengo otro medio
de jabón y aquí tengo otro medio de
jabón por lo tanto tres entre dos es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme a tres
este tres de aquí y multiplicarlo a su
vez por a 123 tengo tres mitades de
jabón multiplicarlo a su vez por un
medio y seguramente aquí vas a decir que
esto está bastante interesante porque 3
dividido entre 2 y bueno recuerda que 2
lo podemos ver como dos hombres uno es
exactamente lo mismo que tres por un
medio y esto seguramente debe hacer que
tu mente esté a punto de explotar cómo
podemos pasar de una división
la multiplicación y lo único que hice
fue tomarme el inverso de 2 es decir un
medio y bueno nosotros sabemos por
cuestiones de multiplicación por
fracciones que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que tomarme 33 entre 23 medios es
decir que 3 entre 2 es lo mismo que tres
por un medio y es justo la
representación que tengo aquí y esto es
lo mismo que tres medios esto está
genial porque de un ejemplo y de un
problema que tiene que ver con jabones
estamos llegando a un resultado
sorprendente 3 entre 2 es exactamente lo
mismo que 3 por un medio que es
exactamente lo mismo que tres medios